[Music]
hello everyone my name is arjun and
today i'm going to be showing all of you
12 dynamic chess gambits
let's get on to the first one
so the first of the 12 dynamic chess
gamets i'm going to be showing you guys
is called the king's gambit
and this is one of the most well-known
gametes in chess and it begins like this
e4 e5 and now white plays the move f4
the move f4 it's its point is that if
black tries to take the pawn for example
if black takes
then what white wants to do is he wants
to just continue his development
normally
bringing his pieces out all to normal
squares
but the thing is now that the pawn is no
longer on e5
white will be able to play the move d4
eventually so that's the whole point of
the king's gambit to try and get a big
center
and if black doesn't know how to play
against it it can be a very useful
weapon
so clearly white would want to play the
move d4 right now just to gain control
of the center but the issue with that is
that black will play the move queen to
h4
since f pawn's already moved this line
is vulnerable
and so now white's king will have to
move to the to the square e2
and this is clearly going to be bad for
him because obviously
you would like to castle in the opening
so before white plays d4 they would want
to play knight f3
to protect the square h4 now there
are many good options for black and one
of the most common is to play the move
g5
the idea of the move g5 is to protect
this f4 pawn
because if white got his way he would
play the move d4
knight c3 and bishop picks f4 and his
position would be wonderful
but this move g5 doesn't make things so
easy for white
and so now white has to come up with
something to do
probably the best move for white here is
to play h4 trying to undermine this pawn
chain that black has come up with
firstly if black tries to play the move
h6 to protect his pawn chain
then after h takes g5 h takes g5 he
loses his rook
so h6 is not a good move
if instead f6 is played things are
nearly as bad
because instead of h takes g5 white can
play the move knight takes g5
and the idea behind this is that once
black takes back i can play the move
queen to h5
forcing king to e7 only go move
and now i can take this pawn with check
notice that his queen is skewered so
black will either have to play knight to
f6
blocking this blocking the track or king
to e8 where his queen is still protected
if the move king to e8 is played then
white can play the move
queen to e5 which is a pretty easy way
of winning
but an even better move is to play queen
to h5
yet again and now after king to e7 only
legal move
queen to e5 is a fork on the king and
rook and white will win
now just one more thing that can happen
here if black plays the move knight to
f6
then what white can do is he can simply
play the move e5
pinning attacking this pin knight and
white will get his piece back next move
so after those inferior moves h6 and f6
we come to the only we come to the last
two sensible moves that black has
one of them is to play g4 which is
probably the best move for him
after the move g4 white has a few
different plates he can move his knight
clearly it's not good to go to g1
because it's bad to retreat your pieces
generally
so white should play the move knight to
e5
now this g4 pawn is being double
attacked and there are a few options for
black
one option is he can try to play the
move d6 just continuing development
but after knight takes g4 things are
pretty good for white
black has doubled isolated pawns on this
open file right here
and although white's knight on g4 is
misplaced that is pretty much made up
for by the fact that these pawns are so
weak
so white's position is fine here
instead if black tries to play the move
queen to e7
aiming to take this e4 pawn next move
after white takes here
that doesn't really help black either
because what white can do is he can just
play the move
d4 protecting the knight and now if the
knight is kicked away
black white can just take the pawn take
the pawn on g4 and now if queen takes e4
white can just play queen to e2 and
though he's down a pawn
these two pawns are doubled and isolated
and they will likely fall
soon so white is doing completely fine
here as well
the final line in this variation i'd
like to take a look at
is instead of the move queen to e7 on
move 5
black can try the move h5 which is a
very aggressive
move aiming to keep this g4 pawn this
move however is not too good either for
black
because white can play the move bishop
c4
this move double attacks the f7 pawn and
since
f7 and f2 as well tend to be the weakest
pawns in the opening
this is pretty bad for black one way he
can try and defend the pawn is to play
the move knight h6
but after knight h6 y can simply play
the move d4
and now after this this f4 pawn is
likely to fall
after virtually any move that black
plays
and after what takes it he'll have the
threat of bishop takes h6
removing the defender of this f7 pawn
this is an example of just how the game
could continue black can try and
get the best for his pawn but things
won't end up being too good for him
and white's position is slightly better
in here
the second gambit i'd like to talk about
is called the danish gambit
and in my opinion this gamut can be even
more aggressive than the king's gambit
it starts off normally enough e4 e5 and
now white plays the slightly uncommon
move
d4 this is called the center game
and black will normally take back on
with the e pawn
now a few options for white include
queen takes d4 simply recapturing the
pawn
knight to f3 aiming to recapture with
the knight next move
and the move that we're going to be
looking at c3
this move gambits upon and it's not
the most common move in this position
people tend to prefer queen takes d4 and
knight f3
but after this black has a few choices
the best move is just to accept the
gambit with d takes e3
and if white plays the move knight takes
c3 we're in what's called the goring
gambit
however we're not talking about the
gambit in this video we're talking about
the danish gambit
and in the danish gambit white
sacrifices a second pawn with the move
bishop to c4
this move gets out the bishop aims at f7
and now
after the most common move c takes b2
white can take back with the bishop
and now he is down two pawns but he has
two bishops out that are aimed right at
the black king side
here there are a few good options for
black and one of the most common moves
here is to play the move d6
and d6 is just a pretty safe move in
this position
black already knows that his position is
not
is not very good because although he is
better here
the thing is although he's up to pawns
he's very behind in development
so it seems like it would be a good idea
to play safely
after the move d6 white should just
continue development normally with
knight to f3
and now there are a few options for
black probably a good move here would be
to play knight c6
but before we look at that i'd just like
to show a little trap
if black tries to play bishop to g4 then
white can play the move bishop takes f7
and now if king takes f7 i can play the
move knight to e5
preparing to recapture on g4 next note
that the pawn can't take
because the queen will hang so after the
move king he ate
white can take back the bishop and he
will be better because black has lost
his right to castle
however blue bishop to g4 is not likely
to be played
so it's better it's better to also be
prepared for other lines such as knight
to c6
here black white should just castle and
now black has a few options
if black tries to play a move like for
example knight to f6
then white can play the move knight to
g5 which although it looks pretty simple
it's actually very good and white is
much better in this position
white is now double attacking this f7
pawn with the knight in bishop
and the only way for black to even
attempt to defend is to play bishop e6
but unfortunately for him after knight
takes e6
f takes bishop e6 white will be better
just because now black king is even more
open than it was earlier
white is also ahead in development and
on top of that
white is now only down one pawn
so if black tries to play overly safe
then bad things can happen
and the best way for white for black to
continue is to play bishop e6
and the thing that this does is it
blocks this bishop line on
f7 so now white can continue with a move
like knight to g2
protecting his bishop and now after a
move like knight f6
white can just play bishop take c6 f
takes e6
and now the game will continue after
move like knight g5
now black can play a move like e5 and
now the ideas for both sides are pretty
simple
white can play move like queen b3 which
double attacks is f7 pawn
this b7 pawn and the f7 square
threatening checkmate
and now black can play move like queen
to d7 and now white can play something
like
f4 aiming to open up this file
here white's position is pretty
aggressive and although he is down two
pawns
the game is going to be very count
competitive
so instead of the move d6
black can try other moves such as a move
like bishop to b4
and this is not a very common move d6 is
definitely more common than this
but white should just play and move like
knight to c3 getting his pieces out
already there is another trap that black
can fall into
if he tries to play the move d6 aiming
to get this bishop out
to one of these squares
then white already can win some material
by playing the move queen to b3
the idea behind this move is this b4
bishop is being attacked now
and the queen and bishop has fought have
formed what is not what is called a
battery on the f7 pawn
if black tries to play the move knight
c6 protecting the bishop
white can play the move bishop takes f7
winning a pawn and
get n getting rid of black's white to
castle
instead if the move bishop takes c3 is
played white can play bishop take c3
back
and now after a move like knight f6
protecting the g7 pawn
bishop takes f7 and black and white has
a pretty big advantage
so one last move that i'd like to take a
look at is actually the most common move
here
and that is the move d5 giving back one
of the pawns to try and get some extra
development
what should now take back with the
bishop and you'll notice you may notice
already that this move has a pretty big
threat associated with it
if black just plays a move like c6 very
obvious aiming to get rid of this bishop
so that the queens can get traded
so that the queens can be traded well
white has a stunning tactic
and i'll try and give you a moment to
find it
the tactic that white has in this
position is he can play the move bishop
takes f7
and now the king can't take because of
queen takes d8
so if king e7 is played white can just
play bishop to a3
forcing king takes f7 after which queen
d8 will win a queen
so the best way for black to continue is
with knight f6
and at first glance you may think that
it falls into the same trap
right bishop takes f7 if king e7
then maybe something like bishop a3 for
example
but things aren't actually as good for
white here as they seem in this position
can you find out the way that black
survives this attack
i'll give you a moment to find it
the way that black survives this is he
finds a counter tactic with the move
king takes f7
white will take the queen of course and
he's feeling very excited about his
prospects
but now black plays the discovered check
bishop to b4
now after this move black white will
have to do something like for example
queen to d2
note that if the queen moves if the king
moves then
the queen falls for free
and after white plays move like queen to
d2 bishop takes d2
and now knight takes d2 the material
situation is now equal
black has two extra pawns on the queen
side that are balanced by by white's two
extra pawns on the king side
white black has this light square bishop
compared to white's dark sword bishop
and the position is roughly equal here
because material is equal
and both sides have roughly equal
development so this is just an example
of a middle game that the danish gambit
can continue into
the third game i'm going to be showing
is also a very and wild a very
wild and aggressive gambit and it's
called the evans gambit
this gambit begins the same way as the
other two e4 e5
knight f3 knight c6 bishop c4 and now
bishop c5
from here the most common moves are
moves like d3 z3
and knight c3 but instead white plays
the move b4
which at first sight looks very very
strange
why would white give up a pawn for free
you ask
well after the move bishop takes b4
white plays the move c3
and all of a sudden his purpose becomes
clear
after the bishop moves away to any of
these squares really
white will play the move d4 aiming to
get a big center
after the move bishop a5 which is the
most common white can play d4
now after e takes d4 you'll notice that
since this pawn is pinned
c takes d4 is no longer a possibility so
white will just castle
now c takes d4 is white's threat and
after that he will have a big center
there are a few different options for
black in this position
one of them is to play the move detect
c3 trying to get a second pawn
and from here black is actually up three
entire pawns
however even if this pawn falls since
it's quite weak black will still be up
two pawns white should continue by
playing the move queen to b3
and this double attacks the f7 pawn
which surprisingly is somewhat hard to
defend
black has a few options as to how he can
defend it one of them is to play the
move queen to f6
after queen f6 white can play them with
bishop g5
trying to move the queen away the queen
has to go to g6
to continue protecting this pawn white
can just take back his c3 pawn now
only down two pawns at the moment after
bishop takes c3
queen takes c3 now white black can play
the move knight f6
simply getting his pieces out white can
play e5
aiming to push the knight away and after
knight and move like knight to e4
i can play queen e3 and after castles
and a move like bishop f4 the game will
continue
it's true that white is down two pawns
but the position is actually pretty
close to equal here
and that's just because since this
knight is on e4
you'll notice that all of its all of its
squares they can move to
are defended so the knight can become a
target for white after
move like for example bishop to d3
and the way that white can continue is
by attacking this knight
and aiming to stop the advance of these
of this d-pawn
this bishop is actually almost trapped
on c8 because the d-pawn is kind of
blocked by this e5 pawn
and the bishop
so that is how you can play after the
move d takes c3
trying to get an extra pawn but there
are other options
the most common move is knight g to e7
and the reason that this is played more
often than knight f6
is because after the move bishop a3 it's
very difficult for black to get castled
knight f6 is another option we'll be
taking a look at later so
knight gt7 is played and now white can
play c takes d4 getting back the pawn
now if black tries to just castle then
the way that white will continue is by
playing d5
after the move d5 black really only has
two options for his knight
one is knight to b4 but after knight to
b4 white can play the queen a4 attacking
this bishop
the bishop cannot move because then the
knight will hang
if the move c6 is played to protect the
bishop then white can play the move d6
attacking the knight and if the knight
moves away then
white can play the bishop g5 attacking
the queen
and black's pieces are very tied up on
the queen side so white is better here
instead black can also play the move
knight to b8
and the idea of this is that he doesn't
want to get his knight trapped on b4
now white should play the move d6 which
which blocks the d-pawn from advancing
and if c takes d6 white can play bishop
to a3
trying to get this pawn back next move
and after for example a move like knight
to c6
white can play the move bishop takes d6
and now since this knight is pinned
uh white is actually not doing too bad
not
doing badly because he's only down one
pawn here
but this bishop is going to have a
really difficult time getting out
the only way really is to play b6 and
bishop b7
but that blocks his bishop on a5 from
getting in the game
so you can see that black is going to
have a have to spend a few more moves
sorting out his pieces and meanwhile
white has very easy development of all
of his remaining pieces
a third alternative for black in this
original position
after castles is to play the move knight
to f6
after knight f6 white is going to play
the move e5
attacking the knight the knight clearly
doesn't want to go to g8
so its remaining options are to go to e4
g4
and h5 if knight to g4 is played
then white can just play bishop to g5
and now if
f6 after e takes and if knight takes
here
rookie 1 and if it moves like 97
then white can just play bishop f6 g
takes f6
and now move like even for example
knight to e5
aiming to play queen h5
and if after e takes f6 if the move g
takes f6 is played
white can just play bishop f4 and now
this knight is sort of stranded on g4
so things are not looking too good for
black in this variation
clearly if knight infinite h5 is played
g4 can be played
trapping the knight or sorry no not g4
g4
is actually not a very good move just
because of the move d5
and now if e takes d6 bishop to g4 so
don't play the move g4 you should
instead try to move knight to g5
and this attacks the knight and double
attacks the f7 pawn
so white is better
because of this an unexpected third an
unexpected fourth alternative pops up
which is the move d5 attacking this
bishop
while the knight is being attacked the
way that white should continue to play
this
is he should play e takes f6 getting the
knight
g takes c4 taking the bishop f takes g7
rook g8 and now white can play the move
rook e1
and from here black should block with
the bishop and now
white can play bishop g5 attacking the
queen
queen g5 and now things are actually
pretty strange here because after we
move like knight to d2
if black tries and takes back this rook
white can play the move knight to e4
attacking this weak f f6 square because
if the knight gets to f6
the king and queen will be in a fork
so from here the position is very wild
and there are many alternatives
which i'm not going to be covering in
this lecture but if you do choose to
play the evans gambit
make sure you know all of these lines
the fourth gamut i'm going to be showing
is the staunton gambit
and the stunting gamut begins with the
move d4
the staunch and gamut occurs when black
plays the dutch defense which is d4
f5 now
white should play the move e4 which
initiates the strontium gambit
after the move f takes e4 but should
play knight to c3
attacking this e4 pawn already black can
kind of fall into a trap
if he tries to play the move d5 hanging
onto this pawn
you can try and find the tactic here for
white it's pretty simple
i'll give you a few seconds
the move that white can play to win some
material is queen to h5
check and now regardless of what move is
played
white will take back the pawn and from
this position this e4 pawn is going to
be very weak and the c7 pawn is already
under attack
so white is better
because of that if black wants to
continue normally he should play knight
to f6
simply protecting this pawn now white
plays the move bishop to g5
and now once again if black tries to
protect his pawn with d5
bishop takes f6 e takes f6 queen to h5
will win the pawn back
so from here white's threat is clear to
play bishop takes f6
knight takes e4 and the best thing for
black to do
is actually just to ignore the threat
really he could play move like knight to
c6
after which fight should just play the
move d5
attacking the knight and from here there
are a few options for black
the best one by far is to play the move
knight e5
and if he plays the move knight a5 for
example b4 will be played
trapping it knight to b8 is obviously
not going to be a good move
and that's just because it's bad to
retreat your pieces your original
squares
knight to b4 after the move a3
knight a6 black's knight is pretty
misplaced on a6
and just one sample line after knight e5
white can play the move queen to d4
and after knight f7 white could just
take back here
if you wanted although in this position
it just loses
because of this so
it's best for white to just protect the
bishop with for example knight to h3 and
then take the pawn back later
instead what black can do and this is
also a very common move
is to play e6 just continuing
development
and after this line white should just
plain knight takes e4
getting back to pawn if knight takes
bishop d8 wins
and so instead after 94 black should
break the pin with bishop e7
takes takes c3 block
blunting this bishop's diagonal castles
bishop to d3 and the position is very
normal here
so white should be happy with how the
opening has gone if this comes
if this line comes to be true
the fifth gambit i'm going to show is
another gamut starting with d4
and it's also another one for white it
starts off with
d4 d5 e4 which is this font you can get
which is not the starting gambit sorry
it's called the black mardimer gambit
now black will normally take on e4 but
just something you should know
uh if you choose to play this you should
also have an have a response to e6
the french defense or c6 which
transposes into a caracan
from here after d takes white can play
knight to c3 aiming to take back this
pawn
black should just play knight f6
protecting it and now here's where the
real gambit part of this opening
initiates and that's with the move f3
offering black to take the pawn
black should take it and now after
knight takes f3
white is down upon you'll notice that
his f pawn and e pawn are gone
compared to just black's d-pawn but he
is ahead in development
and his position may be easier to play
later on
now there are a few options for how
black can play knight to c6 is one
option and bishop to g4 is another
option
if bishop to g4 is played white should
play h3
attacking it and now if bishop h5
which is the most obvious move here why
should just play g4
pushing the bishop back once again
bishop g6 and now i can play knight e5
learning to trade it off after a move
like e6
white can trade pieces and play
something like bishop to g2
and now his position is pretty good
because not only does white have the
bishop pair
this b7 pawn is going to be pretty
annoying to defend for black
and what white can do is he can just
develop his pieces all to normal squares
and note that his rook will also have an
open file when it gets developed
so instead of bishop to g4 another good
option is to play knight to c6
which black can do from here
white should play the move bishop to b5
attacking the knight
now black might just continue developing
with e6 and now from here
white can castle and now after a move
like mission b7
white should play a move like for
example bishop takes c6
and after b takes black has these
doubled isolated pawns which white will
be targeting
white can play the move knight e5
attacking this pawn
black will probably play the move bishop
to b7 for example
and now white can just continue his
development
and from here you'll notice that this
bishop on b7 is sort of being blocked by
the c6 pawn
making it less useful and meanwhile
white's knights here are
in very good positions and really
white's only bad piece will be his
bishop on e3
compared to black's bishop on b7 so from
here white will have a comfortable game
where he can try and attack the c6 pawn
in as many ways as possible
the sixth gambit i have prepared is
called the cochrane gambit
and this one is another e4 gambit for
white
it starts off with the move e4 e5 knight
f3
and knight f6 so that's the petrov
defense
white plays the move 95 taking the pawn
and black continues on the main line
with the move d6
now most of the time white will play the
move knight to f3
but to play the cochrane gambit he
should play knight takes f7
which at first glance seems kind of a
ridiculous move
because he's just giving away a knight
but
after king cheeks f7 it becomes clear
what white's intent was
since the e5 pawn had already been taken
by white sacrificing for the f7 pawn
means that white has two pawns
specifically these two pawns
for black extra knight which in general
is not a terrible material
which is not a terrible material balance
for the two pawns
now from here what should continue with
the move d4 simply gaining control of
the center
and already black can fall into a trap
with the move knight takes e4
if this is played white will win back
some material with the move queen to h5
if g6 is played queen to d5 works the
knight
if king to e7 is played then white can
just play queen to e2
and if the move d5 is played then in
this exact instance
bishop g5 will win the queen
and if something else is done like for
example king f7 then the knight will
fall
and from here if the move king to g8 is
played queen z5 will be checkmate in two
so clearly knight takes e4 is not
black's best bet
black should instead play a move like
for example knight to c6
continuing development now white can
protect the e4 pawn with knight c3
black might play bishop b7 and
developing and from here after move like
bishop to c4
check king f8 and now you'll notice that
black's king is almost stuck in the
center
it can't really go to the king side
because of this very annoying bishop on
c4
and now black white's plans are actually
going to be pretty simple
i can play castles and
if black just continues developing
passively why would play f4
e5 and if just black does nothing of
course
black should not play these exact moves
well
if this happens of course he'll lose a
piece and you'll notice that it's very
difficult to defend against white's
upcoming attack
so this position this line can be very
pleasant for white if he plays it
properly
now instead of playing knight to c6 the
most common move is to play c5 which
tries to encount which tries to counter
in the center
from here white should play the move
knight to c3 just getting another piece
out protecting the pawn
and now if black plays the move c takes
d4
white can just play the move bishop to
c4 and now
if the move king f8 is if the move king
e8 is played
after queen to d4 knight c6
queen d1 uh white's ideas are to once
again
castle play f4
and play e5 and once again it's not too
easy to stop these ideas
and the position is roughly equal here
instead here it should be noted that if
d5 is played
trying to double attack both of these
pieces white can just take back with the
knight
so d5 is an okay move but white has a
way to refute it
instead of the move c5 one last option
for black is to try to move queen to e7
and after queen e7 the idea of this is
simple
since knight to e4 and the original
position did not work why not take it
with the queen instead
white will prob white should play the
move knight to c3 protecting it
now if the move knight e4 is played once
again
then white has the exact same idea he
had in the previous
situation after the move g6
queen to g5 will win a piece
so from here uh if black just tries to
continue developing would like knight c6
then i can play bishop to c4 and i this
position might begin to seem familiar
right now for good reason
after a move like king e8 white will
castle and
the plan is you might have guessed it f4
e5
f takes e5 and now white and after that
white will have very strong pieces
and black's king will not be safe so
this line can be very good for white
the sixth gambit i have to show is
another one that occurs in e4
and this one actually occurs in the
sicilian defense
here white plays a very rare move and
that move is b4
the idea of b4 is pretty simple when you
think about it
if c takes b4 white will eventually want
to play the move d4 and gain control of
the big center
so after the move c takes b4 instead of
playing d4 immediately
white plays the move a3
now there are a few options for black
either he can accept the gambit
immediately
or play the move d5 and since d5 is a
more common move
i'm going to be looking at that one
first
if the move d5 is played now what white
should do is you should take on d5
the pawn and now queen takes d5 and make
sure if you play this gambit
never to play hxb4 here this actually
happened in the u.s championship many
years ago
where this exact position was reached
and after the move 25
white resigned because of this tactic
so make sure that after he takes d5 you
do not play hxb4
and now white should just play the move
d4 protecting against the square
now black will often play b takes a3
just protect
just taking the pawn and now after this
y can just play knight takes a3 and both
sides will just develop normally really
knight f3 e6 c4
queen i5 bishop d2
queen to d8 and bishop d3
and in this position this is as far as
they'll go in this line
you'll notice that white has all of his
minor pieces out and
all of them except for this bishop on d2
really will be on pretty good squares
meanwhile black only has one piece out
and this bishop on d7 is not a very good
piece either
so the position is roughly equal here
just because white's material
or black's material black's material
counters white's extra development
so instead of playing b takes a3 in this
exact position
another option is to play knight to c6
now after knight c6 white should play
knight f3 protecting the pawn
now there are a few options here one of
them is to play the move bishop to g4
and now after the move c4 which is what
white should do
if b takes c3 knight takes e3 queen a5
this is what could happen
white can play bishop to d2 and now
you'll notice that there is this
discovered this possibility for a
discovered attack on the queen
but if you look at the squares white's
knight has access to none of them will
really do any damage to the queen
so black should just continue developing
normally like e6
now white can play rook b1 attacking
this b7 pawn
queen c7 d5 opening up the center
since black's king is still stuck there
e takes
knight takes queen d7 bishop c4 and the
position is very interesting here
because although
he is down a pawn white will be able to
castle in one move
and then play him to move rook to e1
next so
white's position is pretty good here in
my opinion
and the last line i'd like to take a
look at in the wing gambit
is what can happen if instead of instead
of the move d5
black accepts the game immediately with
b takes a3
white should display bishop takes a3 and
black may develop with a move like
knight to c6
white can play d4 gaining control of the
center
queen to a5 and now he can play move
like c3
blocking the track if
black plays the move knight to f6 then
here what white should do is he can play
a move like for example
bishop to d3 except the issue with this
is that knight takes g4 will win a pawn
so black should white should definitely
not play that
instead a move like queen d3 would be
better because
knight takes d4 is no longer a thread
now from here black might play a move
like g5 aiming to counter in the center
white can play e5 attacking this knight
after we move like 94 white can attack
the knight a bit
and then after a few more moves both
sides will just continue their
development
and from here the ideas for both sides
are pretty simple once again
black wolf and kettle his bishop in a
few moves and castle kingside
white on the other hand will aim to use
this at this active rook on this file
he'll also castle and the squares that
white we'll be trying to get control of
are c5 a very powerful square and
an f4 f5 plan is also not going to be
out of the question
these are just some of the lines that
can occur if you choose to play the wing
gambit
gambit number eight for today is called
the latvian gamut and this is the first
game i'm going to be showing
that black can play this scam it starts
off with e4 e5
white plays knight f3 and now black
plays the very rare move
and perhaps it's slightly dubious f5
which initiates the latvian gambit
now bla white has a choice of two
different free pawns to take
and let's look at the move e takes f5
first
if e takes f5 is played white black
should play the move e4
attacking the knight after after the
move e4
white has a few options if knight to e5
is played
then then there's this really complex
line that can occur
after a move like knight to f6 bishop to
e2
and now the move d6 and from here
there's there's very complicated lines
that occur after we move bishop to h5
i won't be going through all of them but
i'll just give you a taste of what can
occur
after bishop takes h5 checking the king
black should play king to e7
and now white can try to fork the king
and queen like this
now white will play black will play the
move queen to e8
and once black once white takes the rook
black can take the bishop
and from here black's king is not going
to be very safe
white is up in exchange but this this
knight on h8 is not going to is probably
not going to survive
and i'm not going to be going through
all of these lines right here
because if you want to play the latin
gamut you should just research these
ones on your own
so instead just something else that you
should be aware of
if white plays the move knight to c4
black can just play bishop takes f5
and from here his position is completely
fine if bishop takes
bishop to h5 white black can just take
and play the move g6
so one more line in the e takes f5
variation
if if white chooses to play knight to g4
instead
white black can play the move queen to
f6
this attacks the knight and now if the
move c3 is played to protect it
black can white black changes play
knight to c6 and after takes
takes queen e2
black can just play bishop takes f5
protecting this pawn and now black will
either castle queen side
or develop these this develop these
pieces
and castle king side
the other possible line for white in the
latvian gamut
is instead of playing e takes f5 to play
the move knight takes e5
from here there are a few options for
black one of them is to play the move
queen to f6
after queen to f6 like black white can
play the move d4
aiming to keep the knight on e5 black
can play d6
followed by knight c4 and now black can
just take the pawn back on e4
if black tries knight c3 white can play
if white tries knight to c3 excuse me
black can play the move queen to g6
protecting the pawn
and now after a move like f3 trying to
get rid of this pawn
the game will just continue like this
and after queen to f6 another possible
option is for
is for white to play the move knight to
c4 and this knight to c4 line isn't too
complex white black can just play after
c4
and now if if a move like for example
knight c3 is played
black black can just let the pawn go
after mood like c6
allowing this possible variation and
sorry no not that move
queen to h5 and things will be very
complicated in this line
the knifecam i'm going to be showing is
one of the best in my opinion for the
side that plays it
it occurs for black once again and it
starts off in the scandinavian defense
e4 d5 after e takes d5
black plays the move knight to f6 aiming
to recapture the pawn with the knight
now most of the time white will play a
move like d4 for example
but in order to play the icelandic gamut
white should play the move c4 here the
two best moves for black are to play e6
or c6 both of which gambit upon
the icelandic gambit is the move 3 e6
and now the vast majority of the time
white will recapture
now black should recapture with the
bishop and now there are many different
lines that white can play
but the one i'm going to be focusing on
is is pawn to d4
so now black should play the move bishop
to b4 track
and there are a few different ways for
white to block the track
if bishop d2 is played then black should
just take the bishop
queen takes and now queen e7 aiming to
discover check the king
if a move like queen e2 is played then
black can just play the move knight to
c6
and if d5 is it a pawn fork well
not exactly like black can play d knight
to d4
and if a move like queen to d2 is played
bishop f5 track
followed by something like this
will win a lot of material
so from here if this line occurs white
should just play queen to e3
after which once again knight to c6
could be played
and if d5 then white can play then black
can play knight to g4 attacking the
queen
if here is played then the pawn will
fall
so that is one example of what can
happen if bishop d2 is played
instead another option is to play the
move knight to c3
blocking a check a different way
now here black should play the move
knight to e4
attacking this pin knight and from here
there are several ways that white can
try to defend this
one of these ways is to play the move
queen to b3
but the issue with that is why is that
black can just play knight to c6
protecting the bishop once again if d5
is played
knight to d4 will be very powerful
because in this line
black can just go this that can just do
this for example
and this position is very very good here
instead of playing queen to b3 white can
also try to play the move knight to e2
to protect it but from here black could
just play the move bishop takes c4
getting the pawn back
if white tries to move queen to c2 then
what black can do is he can just play
that
knight takes c3 b takes c3 and queen
takes d4
note that this pawn is pinned both ways
because
this can happen and this is impossible
because of this
pin and
the last one i'm going to be showing to
try and protect it is to play the move
bishop to d2
after which the move queen takes d4 can
be played
if knight takes e4 then you can just
play queen takes e4
and after move like 92 a good option is
just to play bishop takes d2
and black has this pawn back the c4 pawn
is very weak
and white is going to have a hard time
castling because of how hard it is to
get this bishop out
so the icelandic game is a very good
gambit for black and i would definitely
recommend that you play it if given the
opportunity
gamut number 10 is possibly the most
widely played out of all these gambits
and you may have heard of it before it's
called the benko gambit
it's another one for black beginning
with the moon d4
after g4 knight f6 c4
black plays the move c5 here so the move
d takes e5 here which
might be the first thing we think of is
not very good just because after e6
black will soon get the pawn back
instead nearly all the time white plays
the move d5
and from here the bengal gambit begins
with the move
b5 another common option is to play the
move e6 which is the binoni defense
but anyways after b5 now black
white will almost always take the pawn
and here black sacrifices another pawn
with the move a6
after b takes a6 white does now what
black does is he plays g6
aiming to fianchetto this bishop and
eventually recapture this pawn
so white can just play the moon knight
to c3 getting the knight out
black can just play the move for example
bishop to g7
but the issue with playing this line is
that
after the move like for example e4
then then after move like castles
and e5 black has to be prepared to play
in this variation
so i'm not really going to be showing
this line
instead i'd recommend you just play the
new bishop takes a6
where e4 is not likely to be played just
because of this connection
so instead after bishop takes a6 the
move g3 is more common
aiming to fianchetto the bishop
black should now play the move d6
stopping this d-pawn in its tracks
now after bishop g2 both sides can fan
counter their bishops
and both sides can castle
and from here it may not look like black
has much in exchange for the pawn
because after all he is still down the
pond black has no lead in development at
all pretty much
and it seems as though white's position
is solid enough right
well that's true but also not true in a
way
after move knight to knight b to d7
white might play the move rook to b1
even to play b4 in the near future
black can play queen a5 and after move
like bishop d2
i can play rook after b8 and here is
where the real power of the bank
of the bengal gambit begins to become
apparent
since these since this a pawn is white's
extra pawn
an apon is generally one of the least
valuable pawns on the board
and since black's true rooks are right
here aiming down this line
these two pawns are very hard to make
use of and
white can barely advance them at all
really that's pretty much the furthest
white can advance his pawns at the
moment
meanwhile black has this extremely
powerful bishop
and this d5 pawn will be a target for a
very long time
which black can aim at with both his
knights and his bishop
so for example a way that the game can
continue is like this
and from here white might play the move
b3
and knight to b6 and it's very difficult
for white to actually make anything
anything happen really on the queen side
just because of how
how strong black's rooks are
and though it may not look like it the
bangko gambit can actually be a very
serious weapon on the queen side because
if even one of white's two pawns here
falls
then the other pawn will end up being
very very weak and black will actually
have a big advantage really if that ever
happens
so the 11th gambit i'm going to be
talking about is called the schliemann
dammit
and this is another one that occurs for
black
it comes in the roy lopez e4 e5 knight
f3 knight c6 bishop b5
and here what black plays the third most
common move
which kind of surprises you it's so high
up
he plays the move f5 sacrificing a pawn
from here white has a few different
options white can try e takes f5
bishop takes c6 or knight to c3 for
example
if e takes f5 the most obvious move is
played
black plays the move e4
from here black white has a few options
the best move is to try queen e2 pinning
this pawn
after which black can play queen e7 note
that the knight doesn't really have any
good squares to move to now
so if white tries knight g1 things are
pretty bad because after the move knight
to d4
this bishop and this queen are not
looking too good
instead if this position happens white
should just play bishop takes c6
d takes c6 knight to d4 and now
black is white is doing okay but the
easiest way for black to continue
is to just play move like knight to f6
eventually black will be able to get
this pawn back just because it's so weak
instead in this position after the move
he takes f5
if black if white tries to play bishop
takes c6
black can just play d take c6 and after
move like knight e5
bishop f5 can be played safely and black
is doing pretty well just because
material is now equal
black has a bishop pair and white's
knight on e5 is kind of out of position
a second option that white can play
after the move f5
is knight c3 which is the most common
move just protecting the pawn
if this happens black is in no real
danger because after
f takes e4 knight takes e4 black can
just play knight f6
and from here there are a few options
if black tries knight takes f6 if white
tries knight f6 the black can just play
queen takes f6
and this pawn on e5 is solid black will
have good development
and most importantly perhaps his king
will be safe which is not something you
can say after every gambit
instead from here another option for
white is to play the move queen to e2
targeting this e5 pawn
from here black should play the move d5
attacking this knight
and now if knight takes f6 what black
can just play detect f6
and as you can see with these arrows
black's two center pawns over will have
good
squares and his king will be safe
castle's queen side
the final option i'll be looking at in
this gambit is the bishop takes c6
after which black should play dtx6
recapturing
the idea of bishop takes c6 in general
is that white wants to play knight takes
e5
which this may remind you of the latvian
gambit once again
white has two different options of pawns
to take in pretty much the exact same
situation
except for except for differences on the
queen side
from here if white has played this he's
likely intending to play in i take z5
after which black should play the move
queen to d4
from here watch your plane knight to f3
note that if queen
h5 is attempted after g6 knight takes
aiming to try and get this rook if g
takes
this this queen is protecting it so
white has achieved nothing
instead from here black can try knight
to f3
after which white can play queen takes
e4 and
if queen e2 black can just take
and the position is solid because black
has the bishop pair
and though he has these double pawns
here his position will be pretty good
that is the schliemann gamut for you
the final gamut i'm going to be looking
at is called the england gambit
and this one is also considered to be
somewhat dubious though it can be very
powerful if used properly
it starts off with d4 and here the moon
e5 is played sacrificing a pawn on move
one
white plays d6 e5 and now black plays
the move knight to c6 aiming to
recapture this pawn
white plays the move knight to f3
getting the knight out and protecting
the pawn
now black can play the move queen to e7
double attacking this pawn
from here there are a few options for
white and the most common is to play the
move bishop f4
and from here one way that black can
continue is by trying to go for this
trap with
queen to b4 white will likely play the
move
bishop to bishop to d2 after which black
can try queen takes b2
if the move bishop take bishop to c3 is
played white has this tactic
with bish black has this tactic my
apologies with bishop to b4
and now from here if black if black
tries to take the queen
if white tries to take the queen he'll
notice it's illegal because of this pin
if black takes his bishop then in this
exact instance knight takes b4 is a bit
stronger
just because of this double attack and
white would be
and black would be winning but
unfortunately black should not go for
this line
and that's just because if one plays the
move knight to c3
and black attempts bishop b4 things are
pretty good for white here
just because after move knight to d5
white will have a lot of threats
so instead of playing the move queen to
b4 black should sacrifice this pawn for
good here with the move d6
and now after the move e takes d6
accepting the gambit
black can play queen f6 double attacking
now white will likely play the move
queen c1 protecting both of these pieces
and now black should take back on d6
after which takes
and takes will occur and now white is
slightly better here just because he's
up a pawn
but the game is far from over and that's
just because
after a position like this
this pawn on e4 is not a very strong
pawn
black will have many many ways of
attacking it for example after rook to
e1
bishop to g4 is a possibility and rook
to d8 is where the other rook will
likely go
with these strong looks on open files
so after you move like bishop d3 black
can just play rookie a
and the game will continue from here
thank you for watching my video about 12
different
opening gamuts i hope you enjoyed and
i'll see you all next time
you